this is GM Daniel nerdinsky we are
watching Anish giri taking on Magnus
Carlson at the 2022 World Blitz
championship and there we have the
handshake the game begins and Anish gear
kicks it off with one E4 and Magnus has
shown a tendency to play the French at
recent Blitz tournaments and he repeats
that he had a crazy game against Richard
report in this exact line we have a win
hour with the Knight coming out to C6
early that is actually quite an uncommon
move Black's Queen typically comes out
to A5 or C7 more frequently than the
development of the night there goes
giri's H Pawn he is not mincing his
words he is making his intentions very
clear as his Pawn is already on H5
Magnus keeps the king side closed and
Gary says no we are opening the G file
whether you like it or not F2 F4 by
anishi has not developed a single one of
his minor pieces he's used his pawns to
try to shatter that King side and maybe
squeeze his Queen in to G7 in fact
taking on F4 here is impossible because
Queen G7 traps The Rook in the corner
but if Magnus doesn't take on F4 then
what does he do Geary is threatening to
take on G5 and simply snap off a Pawn on
the king side and then later on his H5
Pawn if that becomes a passer there will
be hell to pay for Magnus he's got to
get stuff going on the other side of the
board or get stuff going on that side of
the board F5 was an amazing move by
Carlson if Gary had taken on passant
Carlson would have recaptured with the
Knight and kept things closed down now
he's he's been able to push his Pawn to
G4 keep giri's Queen out of commission
Anish he took on C5 he's got the tripled
pawns on the queen side and Magnus going
after those pawns with his last move the
queen finally comes out to A5 C3 is
under pressure C5 is hanging and
anisha's lack of development is kind of
hurting him here I think he needs to try
to get his Bishops out maybe bishop D2
and Bishop D3 and of course the Knight
can't come out to F3 it's natural
developing square but it can still get
out to E2 and Anish with some damage
control there the Knight comes out to E2
straight away so not developing the
Bishops yet still still not developing
the Bishops and still using his pawns to
try to grab some space A4 is standard
fare in the win hour if Magnus takes on
C5 prematurely Anish can put his Bishop
on A3 with Tempo and that Bishop will
slice right down the middle of Black's
position what an interesting move by
Magnus not only does he not take the
pawn he offers the pawn a way out B7 B6
sacrificing the pawn and each can now
take on B6 and Magnus will presumably
capture back with the a pawn and that is
exactly what is happening cbab and the
reason I think Magnus did that is to
guarantee a nice developing Square for
his own light squared Bishop that Bishop
of course has a lot of problems in most
French lines that Bishop can now come
out to A6 and put pressure on Anish
giri's E2 Knight and that is precisely
what is happening as Anish moved his
King away from the center and toward the
king side King F2 a very creative
approach to ensuring King's safety the
center remains closed anisha's up upon
but he's got a disaster of a pawn
structure on the queen side as he slides
the lady over to E3 where it occupies a
nice Central post aiming at the B6 Pawn
keeping magnus's Queen confined on A5
and on his next move I think Anish will
try to put his dark scored Bishop on A3
and maybe squeeze it in all the way to
D6 that is a juice The Outpost right
amongst the trees Carlson taking his
time as he Twirls upon that is something
he frequently does as he Ponders his
possible candidate moves he can snap the
Knight on E2 off the board that'll lead
us to a two Bishop versus two night
position doesn't happen every day at
this level let's see what the world
champion decides and finally he copies
giri's method King he ate to F7 both
Kings occupying symmetrical squares on
the king side and will Geary continue
running his King up no he develops his
bishop and not to A3 but rather to D2
and what he's attracted by is the
possibility of a discovered attack
against Black's Queen Magnus shuts down
that possibility immediately squeezing
his Bishop into C4 now the bishop on D2
is pretty passive but the Knight on D
for is quite active and you centralizes
it offering a nitrate and if Carlson
accepts that trade Geary will recapture
with the c Pawn attacking Black's Queen
and fixing the Lion's Share of his Queen
Side Pawn structure problems Magnus says
no way Jose the queen slides from A5 to
C5 pressuring white tonight and we have
a major battle going on here an epic
battle going on between the minor pieces
and the queen uh the Queens in the
center Geary can now take the Knight on
C6 but that Knight on D4 is very nicely
centralized I think you might want to
leave it in peace and no he does doesn't
take on C6 he goes Knight B5 he's trying
to access the D6 square with his Knight
that would have been a devastating
Outpost and we have a bunch of Trades
Carlson had no choice but to snap the
Knight off the board and we do indeed
have two Bishops for white and two
knights for black and Anish Gary has
kept his extra pawn and not only that
the A4 Pawn is now a passer and since
the Queens are off the board past pawns
have become a lot more dangerous as The
Rook slides from H1 over to B B1 here
reassembling all of his pieces on the
queen side and the battle is going to
now revolve around whether or not white
can really set that A4 Pawn in motion
maybe drive it all the way up to A6 and
keep the knights as confined as possible
Magnus copying Geary's move Rook h8 to
B8 the bishop drops back to E2 a line of
communication is opened between the
Rooks Carlson says I'm taking the Rook
trade and I'm locking out black White's
Bishop with c4o that was an excellent
positional move by the world champion
and look at that Bishop on E2 it is
completely imprisoned both by black
spawns but also by the C2 Pawn which
doesn't let the bishop seek shelter on
D1 that is a big problem for a niche as
he moves his King back to the center
Carlson does the same the bishop drops
back to F2 what an interesting end game
we have all three results are possible
here but Magnus Carlson has done a
superb job of keeping the A4 Pawn in
place it's much harder to shoot at a
moving Target in chess and now Carlson
is ready to move his knight from C8 up
to B6 and actually threaten the pawn on
A4 and if Geary has to get rid of his
dark Squad Bishop then what he's left
with is his other Bishop which as we
know is completely hemmed in by black
spawns white actually might be worse
here and Geary moves his Pawn up to A5
seeing nothing better than just to give
that pawn away oh but look at Bishop C5
to f8 if Carlson nonchalantly takes that
pawn with his Rook then after the Rook
trade Bishop C5 moves into f8 and don't
fall asleep on the H6 Pawn not only will
that pawn be indefensible but dreary
will quickly promote his H Pawn with
Black's pieces stuck on the queen side
frustration there for the world champion
a brilliant idea by Geary and perhaps he
could have considered playing Bishop f8
straight away oh but Carlson goes for it
he takes on A5 what is he planning
against Bishop f8 we're about to find
out oh it's King D7 and his King is in
time his King is just in time to prevent
further progress of the H1 it takes
Theory a Tempo to move his Bishop away
from H6 and Carlson will use his Tempo
to squeeze his own King up to F7 and if
he can contain the H Pawn then his
Knights can be used to attack giri raise
pawns on the queen side black and try to
position a knight on A4 and then perhaps
drag the Knight the other night over to
E4 and don't fall asleep if you're Anish
gear you actually might lose this game
if white loses the C3 Pawn black will
get a pawn majority in the center and
what really hurts White's chances here
is still that that light squared Bishop
which is not participating in any way
neither defensively nor in an attacking
win Geary finally makes a decision he's
down to 20 seconds and time pressure
here for both players but Carlson still
right about a minute as he moves his
Knight back to C6 keeps massaging the
position hesitation for Anish giri he
essentially has to keep treading water
here he moved his King back to C1 now it
goes back to D2 to protect the C3 pawn
and here goes Magnus Knight C6 to A7
another Exquisite maneuver and the
Knight is moving into B5 and Anish Geary
is going to lose the C3 Pawn his Queen
side is starting to collapse there's
King G7 Carlson doesn't let that h-man
move any further three seconds for any
two seconds for any she's gonna move
he's not gonna make it and he lost on
time didn't make his move Carlson
indicating that his clock shows zero
what an Exquisite positional effort by
the world champion and if you enjoyed
this video make sure to click the link
in the playlist for more of these Blitz
videos thank you for watching
foreign